ce monde est d'une cruauté sans nom
faut combattez les reconnaître depuis
des décennies ma famille les combats
depuis des siècles
et elle a été massacrée
j'ai compris mon père ton père me
croyait pas à l'avant chance
nous croyons aux fraises
[Musique]
je ne me battrai pas pour lui je me
battrai pour mon peuple
[Musique]
cette
est-ce que vous croyez en Paul
il y a des signes
le Prophète pourquoi ce serait une
mauvaise chose il faut en servir parce
que toutes mes visions l'esprit âgé des
horreurs
parce que tu perds le contrôle parce que
je le prends
tu crois en moi
Paul a treed est toujours en vie
occupez-vous de ce prophète
[Musique]
autrement qui tu es
votre père
était d'une grande faiblesse
regardez qui revient votre les morts
je ferai ce que j'ai à faire
nous leur avons donné quelque chose à
espérer
c'est un conte je me fiche que tu n'y
crois pas moi j'y crois
je suis Paul moitié
[Musique]
lui qui peut détruire une chose en a le
contrôle
[Musique]